RYAN MATSUMOTO: Cloud Bigtable
is Google Cloud's NoSQL
database designed to
handle large analytical and
operational workloads.
In previous episodes,
we've learned
about Bigtable's speed,
scale, and reliability,
as well as how it's being
used by companies to deliver
personalized experiences
to their customers.
In this episode, we're going
to learn more about how
Bigtable can be used for another
key use case, fraud detection.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The rapid growth of online
retail in recent years
has created new opportunities
for businesses, but also
many challenges.
One big challenge for
retailers is detecting fraud.
This could include credit
card fraud, account takeover,
and promotion abuse.
If fraud isn't
prevented, this could
lead to chargeback fees,
lost inventory, and loss
of customer trust.
Retailers need to
be able to tell
if they should charge
a credit card when
a customer makes a purchase.
At the same time,
they need to make sure
that legitimate
payments go through
and that the process is smooth
and efficient for everyone.
This is where fraud detection
companies come into play,
helping retailers detect fraud
with the power of big data
and machine learning.
Bigtable is great for fraud
detection use cases because
of its scalability and speed.
One challenge that fraud
detection companies
face is the massive
scale of their data.
Whenever a fraud detection
company brings on a new client,
a new set of data and throughput
gets added to their system.
Some of these clients might
have thousands of stores,
billions of dollars
in revenue per year,
and millions of
transactions per day.
Luckily, Bigtable
has the scalability
necessary to handle
large volumes of data.
Bigtable databases can be scaled
with the click of a button
by adding or removing
nodes, which provide up
to 10,000 additional
queries per second,
as well as additional
storage capacity.
This means that fraud
detection companies
can store up to petabytes
of data in Bigtable.
Fraud detection
companies also need
to be able to access
this data at low latency.
When a client's customer
places an order,
the fraud detection
company needs
to retrieve as much
data as possible
about that customer to
detect potential fraud.
This data is then passed through
a machine learning model.
But this whole
process also needs
to be done as
quickly as possible.
You wouldn't want
customers to have
to wait several minutes for
the fraud detection process
to complete before
they can buy items.
Fortunately,
Bigtable's optimized
for handling large numbers
of reads and writes
per second at low
latency, on the order
of single-digit milliseconds.
One way to go about
this is by storing data
for each customer in a single
row of a Bigtable table.
This makes it extremely fast to
lookup data for that customer
when they attempt
to make a purchase.
The row key can be
the customer ID,
and the columns can store data
about orders, transactions,
and payment methods.
Versioning allows you to store
different versions of data
in a given row-column
intersection of a Bigtable
table.
For example, you
could use versioning
to store data about each
of the different payment
methods a given customer
has used over time.
Garbage collection
makes it easy for you
to remove expired or obsolete
data from Bigtable tables.
This can help you limit the size
of your Bigtable rows, which
can improve performance
and keep costs down.
For fraud detection,
you might want
to set a garbage
collection policy
to only keep information about
a customer's last three payment
methods.
Fraud detection
companies can also
take advantage of how easy it
is to integrate their Bigtable
database with BigQuery
for further analysis.
Bigtable's low latency
and scalability
are great for using
it in the serving path
of your application.
But if you want to perform
analysis on your entire data
set, we recommend using our
data warehouse, BigQuery.
While it might make sense
to use Bigtable to look up
data about each
customer individually,
BigQuery could be better
for analyzing data
about multiple
customers at once.
One way to go about this
is to send the same data
to both Bigtable and
BigQuery at the same time.
This would allow data scientists
to run complex queries,
build models, and
investigate patterns
without affecting the underlying
performance of queries
to Bigtable for live
fraud detection.
As you can see, Bigtable's
scalability and speed
make it a great fit for
the unique challenges
of fraud detection.
If you're curious to learn more,
take a look at the links below.
Thanks for joining us today.
And stay tuned for more
episodes about Bigtable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]